la pédagogie de cet établissement
s'inspire de la méthode steiner celle ci
se fonde sur une nouvelle science la
connaissance profonde de l'homme éduqué
est un art dans les années 60 les
premières écoles steiner voit le jour en
france des établissements privés
destinés aux enfants de 0 à 17 ans basée
sur la pédagogie de rudolf steiner un
philosophe occultistes autrichien du
début du 20e siècle
à l'origine de cette nouvelle méthode
d'enseignement l'enseignement se fait
par époque pendant deux à trois semaines
chaque jour la même matière principale
quand la concentration atteint la
lassitude on cesse de telle sorte qu'ils
les responsables que l'enseignement est
vécue par l'enfant et non pas imposer
une pédagogie basée sur un courant
ésotérique l'anthroposophie une approche
globale de l'enseignement qui vise à
développer les facultés intellectuelles
et artistiques de l'enfant l'art du
mouvement fait aussi partie des piliers
de steiner bouger pour mieux apprendre
pour que les symétries de l'écriture ne
soit pas abstraite ans les leur fera
vivre de leurs propres mains plus tard
ils apprendront ce qu est un verbe en
l'exécutant puis l'adjectif et enfin le
nom la pédagogie steiner continuera de
se développer en france mais de façon
très marginale dans les années 90
seule une dizaine d'écoles existent
contre 200 en allemagne où la pédagogie
est parfaitement intégré au système
éducatif en 1992 l'école steiner de
santa nu dans l'allier faisait partie
des rares écoles françaises écoles ne
prépare pas un examen
elle prépare à la vie ce qui est très
différent
ici comme dans toutes les écoles steiner
les enfants n'apprennent pas lire et à
écrire qu'à partir de 7 ans voici les
raisons évoquées par ce responsable en
1992 si on commence à faire
l'enseignement avant sept ans eh bien on
va prendre à ce corps physique des
forces
on va lui envoyer des forces et scheiner
dit ça c'est le lit pour des maladies
telles que la sclérose une cancer par
exemple des préceptes flou épinglé en
juin 1999 dans un rapport d'un
inspecteur de l'éducation nationale
leur conclusion était plutôt alarmistes
tous les programmes d'enseignement sont
basées sur des thèmes mythique et
mystique
les activités ne laisse aucune place
pour l'esprit critique
il y a des carences dans l'éducation
scientifique technique dans l'histoire
les savoirs enseignés sont parfois
erronées
après cette enquête l'éducation
nationale dénoncera quelques manquements
en matière de santé publique et de
sécurité mais ne trouvera aucune trace
de lien sectaires dans les écoles
steiner aujourd'hui sur les 23
établissements français 5 sont même sous
contrat avec l'éducation nationale
[Musique]